Hello everybody! Welcome back to the next
Jam Session
for the FP101 course.
What we're going to do this time
is to look at functional programming in
Dart.
Dart is a new language from Google
aimed at programming web applications.
And Dart has great support
for functional programming. If you come
from Java or from C#
you will feel immediately familiar with
the Dart syntax.
And if you followed the Haskell lectures
you will be able to take all the things
you learned there
and immediately apply them to Dart.
Let's open up the editor
and play around with Dart
a little bit and see how we can apply
what we learnt. One interesting
aspect of Dart
is that Dart has optional typing. So it
is not
statically typed, but you can
put in types as you want to.
It's not like JavaScript, where
it's completely dynamically typed,
there's no way to put
type annotations, and I must say in
practice
this works out very very well. The nice
thing about Haskell
is that the Haskell type inference is
very powerful
and so you never have to write any
types yourselves and typically
the compiler will be able to infer
things for you.
But the price you pay for that
is that you have to know there's a
couple of things in Haskell.
Type names have to start with uppercase
symbols. When you have type classes
you use a name in there. It's used
forever. You cannot
have that in a different class.
And in Dart
it's a little bit more
hackerish. And I like that, so let's
open up IntelliJ. I'm using the
Dart IntelliJ plugin. You can
download
that plugin from the IntelliJ
website. You download
the Dart SDK from the Dart website
and off you go.
Like most languages Dart also
uses a main method. So we see here the main
method. We don't have to specify
whether it takes any arguments. And then
here
we just print "hello". The next line here
shows a lambda expression in Dart.
I'm defining a variable f
and its value is a lambda expression
lambda x
x+1. Here you see that this
thing has
a function type. And let's
just try to say f+3.
Let's see
what is does.
Now you see, you cannot see that
it's quite small, I
don't know how to blow up
the type hints, but I will read it for you.
And it says: there is no such
operator + in function. So even though
I didn't put a type
on f, the compiler has inferred
that f has type function and that
there's no
addition operator for function.
But it will just let me continue.
If I want to do this it will
let me do it
because the typing is optional.
I'm not going to do this here, but that's
a beautiful thing.
The type inference tracks the types, but
nothing is forced on you.
The compiler will never slap you on your
wrist and say
Erik, you cannot execute this program.
Here we have our function and we can call it
with 3. Now let's define
another local function. That's another
nice thing of Dart. And we saw that in
other languages like Scala and
Kotlin as well, is that
inside a function you can define a local
function.
Here inside main I'm defining a local function g
and this g can refer to this outer
variable f. So it closes over f.
What g does is it calls
f(x) and then multiplies it by 2.
And then here I print g(4).
Now let's look at
a real higher-order function.
Our good friend twice.
Twice takes two parameters:
f and x, and I call f(f(x)).
You see, this looks just
like the lambda expression
in Haskell.
And if I wanted, we could also
define it like this. We could define
var twice
equals... and now
it looks like the lambda expression form
in Haskell. And if we do it like this
it looks like the function definition
in Haskell, except that there is an arrow
here. If you don't like the arrow
you can use what
we already did here. We can put the
body..
we take the body and we say return
of the expression. And then
we can do other interesting things. So for
example we can
print that we are executing f.
We can mix and match
imperative code with higher-order
functions.
Good. Let's
run our program and see if everything
works as advertised.
Let's go from the top to the bottom.
Let's first run the program
and then check.. that's really quick.
The dart VM
is really fast and the implementation
in IntelliJ is extremely responsive. Here
we say print "hello". On the output we
expect hello.
Then we defined our function f.
We print f(3).
That should return 4 as expected
Then there is g(x) here, that
doubles f(x) so
that should be, if we call that with 4
g(4), calls f
that's 5, that should be 10.
There we go.
And now here we see that we are inside
twice. We print "..."
and then twice
of incrementing 3 twice gives us 5.
So that is
all as expected and there's a lot of
things in Dart
that I didn't show.
One of the things is that Dart has
classes.
And the nice thing is Dart doesn't
have a separate notion of interfaces.
It's unified with abstract classes, so there
is less
syntactic baggage. In languages like
Java or C# there's
abstract base classes, interfaces
whatever.
And in Dart that is
simplified. Let's go here.
The other beautiful thing of Dart:
If we go here and..
Let's go here. If we go to the
Dart language specification.
The Dart language specification
is written by Gilad Bracha, the
same person that wrote the Java Language
Specification.
It's a very very thorough
description of Dart.
It explains everything. And the beauty
of Dart here
is that Dart now supports
new features: async and await
that we are familiar with from C#.
It also supports
so-called syncstar methods, which are
iterators, that we know from
C# and python
and other languages.
PHP also supports iterators.
But the real nice thing here is that Dart
also has support for streams
for asynchronous data streams
which is kind of a combination of
async/await
and the iterator style
of programming. With these three
features I think Dart
is ahead of the game
with respect to other programming
languages.
Because it has full support for both
asynchronous methods, methods that
return synchronous collections
and methods that return asynchronous
collections.
I invite you to take a look at Dart.
There's also a Dart to JavaScript
compiler, so
you can run Dart in a regular browser.
You don't need
the Dart VM. And if you want to
write web applications
and you come from a Java or C#
background
I think Dart is a fantastic choice.
Thank you so much and see you next time.